the current progression of Alzheimer's
disease involves a preclinical stage of
15 to 20 years in which there are no
symptoms by the time symptoms do emerge
significant neurod degeneration has
already occurred after an individual
notices symptoms they can be evaluated
by a doctor who may use cognitive tests
cerebral spinal fluid testing and brain
Imaging to Aid in diagnosis once someone
is diagnosed with Alzheimer's disease
they can begin receiving treatment but
they may not be a good candidate for
clinical trials in which potentially
interventions may be most effective
early on in Alzheimer's disease
progression an alternative to the
current Alzheimer's progression would be
to screen people early on therefore
allowing us to diagnose and begin
treating people before the onset of
symptoms and before significant nerd
degeneration has occurred